last week American Airlines ruled that
fliers can no longer bring goats insects
or hedgehogs aboard their planes as
emotional support animals yeah yeah yes
and it's an outrage Conan the only
reason I'm even at this show today is
because American Airlines wouldn't let
me board my flight with my comfort
insect say hi Eileen say hi this is
Eileen I'm sorry sir sir
I'm sorry is that is that a brown
recluse spider yeah if you're familiar
yes I am sir those are quite deadly yes
they are thank you wait a minute so
holding a spider in your hand they could
very well kill you that comforts you yes
like nothing else gah I'm sorry sir did
that spider just bite you yes and you
know what you're wrong American Airlines
I never felt such comfort oh my god he
either orgasmed or he's dead
[Applause]
just get a dog anymore he's dead yeah
you know what one thing I didn't know is
that when when brown recluse bite you
can hear it yeah you can hear it that's
not what I'm thinking about right
oh it's biting man how long he can hold
that toes he's dying and we're making no
effort to save his life
you